las evacuaciones siguen en Sudán países
siguen enviando aviones para sacar a sus
ciudadanos del fuego cruzado en la
capital jartum hasta el momento Francia
ha repatriado a 500 personas algunos
recuerdan el suplicio que significó la
espera por la evacuación
con todos los mensajes que compartía con
mis amigos y familiares dejar Tum solo
hablábamos de que estábamos esperando la
evacuación esa evacuación era nuestra
esperanza en un punto como la espera era
muy larga pensé que nunca iba a pasar
responsive
sin embargo no todos los civiles en
jartum corren con la misma suerte el
alto comisionado de Naciones Unidas para
los refugiados estima que miles de su
daneses se convertirán en refugiados en
sus países vecinos a consecuencia del
conflicto Sudán era el destino de miles
de refugiados que huían del conflicto de
Sudán del sur ahora tendrán que regresar
a su país huyendo de otro conflicto
la cifra de planificación que tenemos
para el escenario más probable es de
125.000 retornos de refugiado sudaneses
a Sudán del sur y 45.000 refugiados
sabemos que los retornos se producirán
antes proceden en su mayoría de jartum y
es probable que los flujos de refugiados
se produzcan después
Naciones Unidas ha advertido sobre una
próxima gran crisis migratoria resultado
de los combates entre el ejército
sudanés y las fuerzas de apoyo rápido la
gente en Sudán quiere escapar del
conflicto pero los medios con los que
pueden salir dependen de su nacionalidad